in any relationship that matters to us
emotions play a major role in fact when
you say it matters you're saying it's
emotional you're either working to get
positive feelings achievement pride
compliment or to avoid of fear anger
disgust or sadness it's only in Trivial
relationships I used to say when I buy
the newspaper I don't really care I
don't say how are you to the person who
sells it's over here and if I do I don't
really care how they are it's a trivial
relationship that has no relevant past
or future most of our relationships that
matter occur in a context they have a
past they have an intended future and
they have a high level of emotional
engagement even when emotions themselves
are not the main topic which they are in
psychotherapy or they might be in acting
but even when they're not the main topic
they are the topic that tells us how to
evaluate the main topic so if I'm trying
to sell you a car your emotional
response when I mentioned different
options I'll show you different models
different colors when you look at your
wife and shake your head one way or the
other those are all giving me clues as
to how to move in that negotiation the
amazing thing is that emotions have
signals they're not silent thoughts are
silent when I meet someone for the first
time they say oh my god you're gonna
read my mind I say your thoughts are
your own I can't read your thoughts I
can read your feelings I can even read
the feelings that you're unaware of
feeling and I can certainly read the
feelings that you don't want me to know
all of that for the person who's skilled
has learned this is available but not
thoughts I don't know what the feelings
are about I don't know whether you're
thinking about your grandmother or
you're thinking about the President or
his chief opponents thoughts have no
signal emotions are salient with signals
the amazing thing about the face is it's
you
reversal signal system it works for
everyone that is it shows us the same
changes in the face regardless of who
you are and the second amazing thing
about the face and why I focused more on
it then on gesture is that it is the
most precise signal system we have for
the emotions we can read seven different
emotions and we can read whether they're
being falsified and simulated I don't
really feel that way but I want you to
think I do or whether they are genuine
expressions and if they're genuine are
the ones that you are aware of or are
you not even aware of what you're
feeling or are you aware of it and
trying to conceal it from me so I invite
you to join my mentor workshop where you
can learn more about micro-expressions
subtle expressions and other aspects of
nonverbal communication
you